my guest tonight is an emmy-winning
writer actress and comedian you know her
from her work on The New Adventures of
Old Christine Curb Your Enthusiasm the
upshaws and her many many stand-up
specials please welcome to the show the
legendary Wanda Sykes
water Sykes you are here because you
have been the comedians comedian for
decades you've helped mold the very
shape of what American Comedy is you're
the single most consistent performer
I've ever seen and I do not know if I
would be doing what I do if you did not
exist thank you for being here oh wow
for me hold it for me
why thank you Amber thank you so much
that was a lot that was that
almost made me feel look uncomfortable
like my knees my knees started to itch a
little bit
yeah you can't get out of here the doors
are locked
[Applause]
congratulate you
um because
you showed the up Shaws just got renewed
for season three
yes
yes very excited about that you know
love doing the show Mike Epps and uh Kim
Fields and uh but you know so funny that
a lot of people still don't know about
the show yeah well because like Mike
Epps you know he's the co-host and he's
like man I played the clip the trails to
the upshaws before my stand-up gigs and
in the audience goes crazy I was like
I'm gonna do that so I played in front
of one of my shows nothing
they were looking at me like what why
are all these black people on the screen
what am I looking at what is this thing
I asked all I said do you guys know
about the upshaws they're like no I'm
like well it's it's on Netflix and you
know my audience is like majority uh but
white you know so uh it's about third I
don't want you to think that no black
people like me black people love me
[Music]
but it's yeah but it's like maybe like
60 40 right so the and the white people
were all confused they didn't never seen
the show and I'm like oh it doesn't pop
up on your Netflix home page does it
yeah yeah that's the algorithm because I
tell you what if there if it's like
a if it's like friends it's the one
episode where there was a black person
their face is on my thing every time I'm
like yes yes there ain't never no black
people in there no don't be fooled by
the algorithm no right right so I told
them you know search the show and and
watch it and then I apologize for like
really just ruining their homepage I was
like I said you're gonna get a lot of
shows from Nigeria
you don't find black people you didn't
even know existed you're gonna be like
what
what yeah it's yeah but that's the
algorithm yeah everybody loves the
upshaws and it feels like a throwback to
sitcoms you know what I mean I'll I want
to know is that what you wanted
audiences to feel when they watch it
absolutely absolutely because I mean
that's what I grew up on watching was a
you know the old throwback sitcoms you
know and and Mike and I wanted to try to
recapture that uh on that stuff Fred
Sanford you know relationship yeah yeah
you did it yeah so yeah it was totally
intentional but but you know but also it
has to feel fresh has to feel you know
uh contemporary so I have to say with
that
murderer's row of a cast like friggin
Kim Fields and Mike Epps and Wanda Sykes
that's an excellent cast and I it should
the show should be Called Wanda Sykes
Kim Fields and Mike Epps because then
I'm in I'm in no matter what it is yeah
you're gonna watch that no matter what
bank heist I mean I'm like I'd like to
see that okay
um I gotta ask you this
um I'm a huge fan of your stand-up work
uh oh in fact you're performing this
weekend yes yes you're performing this
weekend at the beginning this weekend
yes yes I'm at the at the at the Beacon
yeah for your New York tomorrow night
tomorrow night at the Beacon tomorrow
night at the Beacon that's uh just up
the street yeah so guys
sleep here
then walk up the street you're gonna be
fine
um what do you like best about
performing
um for New Yorkers here in New York oh
well New York this is the the mecca this
is comedy Mecca right I mean you know
this is the this is it this is the big
time you're the Big Show
this is The Big Show because these
people here
are tough yeah they're tough but uh but
you know but they give it up if you did
something they like and they're gonna
they're gonna let you know you know and
yeah exactly so it's yeah
yeah what is because you performed
everywhere all over the world what's the
kindest City and the meanest city as far
as like being generous with laughs oh
wow wow wow you know I was just in I was
just in Durham uh North Carolina and
they were really nice but also I also I
love Denver I love Seattle I love
Atlanta I mean but my favorite though is
DC really
hey I see they give it up I love you
know that's when I started my my comedy
career there so I so I love yeah I love
that audience they they just want you to
win they like just come on you know they
just rooting for you they they want it
yeah we've been working with politicians
all day right us right right yeah yes
any funny thing you could think of say
it to me yeah I need it yes yeah an old
white man help right right right because
and then like it maybe in Durham it was
like it was like look at her she free
she just
you know I think they that's probably
what they love
Hey You Gonna Leave Here
you just go up and leave when you're
done
that white guy is your driver
well yeah I done seen it all
are you prepared for a round of Rapid
Fire questions uh let me get prepared
okay
you do you
here we go
who would you be in Dream Girls Effie
Laurel or Dina oh
Effie oh why not take Center State
exactly exactly who would you be in
Living Single Regine Khadijah Sinclair
or Max oh oh
Max yeah
Max yep Max I'd be Sinclair
uh cat or dog dog all day that's right
that's right if you had said cat
I would have lost a little bit of
respect I know why not yes sir now wait
do you have a cat don't lie I don't have
a cat okay never never had a cat don't
care for them I'm sorry
when does your Christmas tree go up oh
um probably like
like a week before Christmas
maybe 10 days maybe 10 days before
Christmas isn't it
[Music]
my wife likes to I used to go out and
get the live tree so we do the live tree
but it's yeah about like about 10 days
before Christmas about 10 minutes
exactly because you know because you get
it too early to live tree somebody
always forgets to you know water it or
my dog licks the water out the thing
that's right he's right okay look my
shit's going up tomorrow are you serious
yes it no wait a minute no no no no no
no it cannot go up before Thanksgiving
100 no no no
no see now you're infringing on my
Thanksgiving yes no no I'm so sorry no
no no Halloween is Christmas but she's
decorate no no Halloween is Christmas
is also Christmas no no it's
Thanksgiving all the yo no if I am a
church
you let Thanksgiving have this moment
it's a moment under the Christmas tree
no no no no that's wrong that I bet if I
could really cook Thanksgiving food I
wouldn't feel that way
but I'm like you want this food to have
this moment I think not okay well look
at the tree yeah you're like look at the
tree don't eat this my poor
poor hungry husband uh what is your
karaoke go-to song oh
um I uh Let's Groove tonight Earth Wind
and Fire
yeah and and uh and also I uh Since
You've Been Gone Kelly Clarkson
but I love to scream it out yeah you
start a party
um lastly Bell Biv DeVoe or Boyz II Men
uh no it's mean and your answer will be
recorded okay okay
the the the church girl in me wants to
say Boys to Men that's the church girl
living right but the freak is all Bell
bivent
Ah that's the correct answer one of the
sex everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]